[Musique]
bonsoir à toutes bonsoir à tous merci
d'être avec nous sur
tv78 nous sommes le mercredi 22 novembre
voici le programme de ce soir la
gendarmerie des ivelines appelle à la
prudence et à la vigilance depuis le
début de la semaine le nombre de
cambriolage est en hausse les gendarmes
ont ainsi annoncé renforcer leur
patrouille il donnent également quelques
conseils pour éviter tout risque de vol
on fait le point en début
d'émission vous avez 24 heures pour
imaginer les solutions de la défense
spatial de demain c'est le défi qu'a
lancé le pôle de compétitivité Aérospace
vallleé à une soixantaine d'étudiants de
la région parisienne les gagnants de
cette étape sont qualifiés pour la
finale à Paris le 12 décembre du vin du
fromage de la charcuterie des biscuits
et bien plus encore ce weekend se tenait
la 12e édition du salon vin et saveur à
poissie un salon dont la renommée n'est
plus à faire une cinquantaine
d'exposants sont venus de la France
entière pour faire le bonheur des
gourmet certains en ont même profité
pour acheter leurs premiers cadeaux pour
les fêtes de fin d'année et enfin en
deuxème partie d'émission les invités du
78 ce soir nous vous parlerons d'une
fête pour les familles et les enfants en
situation de handicap à plaisir ce sera
avec l'association HS Handicap Société
interre voilà le programme de ce soir
mais tout de suite on va faire le point
sur les informations à retenir
aujourd'hui dans les
Yvelines et c'est avec vous Michel
midoro bonsoir bonsoir Mathilde on
commence avec cette information à
l'approche de l'hiver la nuit tombe plus
tôt et les cambrioleurs en profitent les
chiffres dans le département sont à la
hausse la fin d'année est une période
propice au cambriolage il est estimé que
27 % des intrusions dans les i ont lieu
à cette période selon no confrère du
Parisien lundi 20 novembre au soir pas
moins de H effractions se sont produites
à mant la jolie mais aussi saint-jeananl
et rambouillé un phénomène qui
s'accélère depuis 2 ans 2022 plus de
4600 effractions ont été recensées par
le ministère de l'intérieur ce qui place
les ivelines largement en tête des
départements franciliens l'Est évilinois
est la zone la plus touchée et la
gendarmerie donne des conseils Michel la
gendarmerie appelle à la prudence pour
dissuader les voleurs à le conseil de
laisser les volets fermés lorsque vous
rentrez tard et de ranger les objets de
valeur à l'intérieur si vous vous
absentez dans la soirée pensez à laisser
une lumière allumere pour simuler une
présence et à activer l'alarme s'il y en
a une bien sûr on poursuit ces
informations avec un changement
encourageant dans les ielines le tri des
emballages ménagers et des papiers
progresse d'après nos confrères des
nouvelles avec 2 kg de plus par franc
CEN le tri des déchs ménager est en
légère hausse c'est ce qu'a annoncé
Citeo une entreprise à mission créée par
les secteurs de la grande consommation
et distribution une tendance visible
aussi dans les iines avec 49 kg par
habitant c'est 1,5 % de plus qu'en 2021
mais le département fait quand même
moins bien que la moyenne nationale qui
est de 72 kg et on termine avec du sport
Michel ce weekend promet une belle
rencontre sportif au Vélodrome national
de Saint-Quentin en Eveline c'est la 9e
édition du Grand Prix de véizi sur la
piste environ 120 cyclistes venus de
toute la France s'affronteront chaque
année l'équipe cycliste véisi 78
organise cet événement pour le plus
grand plaisir des sportifs et des
supporters plusieurs épreuves sont
programmées vitesse kirine scratch ou
encore course au point un événement qui
se déroule de 10h à 18h depuis sa
création en 2015 des athlètes de très
haut niveau y ont participé takii Marie
divine Kame championne du Monde 2022
François Pervis SEP fois champion ch du
monde encore les médaillés de Tokyo
Sébastien Vigier Florian gringbau ryanal
et Benjamin Thomas du beau monde du très
beau monde merci beaucoup Michel midoro
pour toutes ces informations et comme
d'habitude si vous aussi vous voyez une
image ou une information qui vous a
marqué près de chez vous n'hésitez pas à
nous la partager sur les réseaux sociaux
en utilisant le hashtag 78
new dans l'actualité yelinoise également
un rassemblement pour la libération des
otages israéliens organisé ce dimanche
par l'association cultuelle israélite de
Versailles et de sa région l'objectif
est de soutenir les familles
israéliennes Murielle vesli la
vice-présidente de l'association répond
aux questions d'annesophie moueké et de
Michael el
[Musique]
midoro tous les dimanches à Versailles
nous avons décidé de faire un
d'organiser un rassemblement en soutien
aux otages et à leur familles pour que
personne ne les
oublie alors nous savons bien sûr que
nos rassemblement ne seront pas décisifs
dans la libération des otages mais ce
que nous souhaitons c'est que un maximum
de gens pensent à eux et se tiennent au
côté de leur famille pour mon que nous
n'oublions
pas tout le monde peut venir et
faites-le savoir et diffusez-le autour
de vous nous vous attendons tous les
dimanches devant la mairie de Versailles
à l'angle de l'avenue de Paris et de
l'avenue du Général de Gaulle de 11h30 à
[Musique]
12h30 la semaine dernière avait lieu le
conseil d'agglomération de Saint-Quentin
en iveline plusieurs points ont été
votés vous allez nous présenter les
principaux Michel midoro et on commence
tout de suite par le COD des ski le
rapport d'activité du CODES ski et ses
futurs projets ont été présentés devant
les élus du conseil communautaire jeudi
dernier le CODES ski c'est quoi c'est
une instance de démocratie participative
de 50 ans livin elle regroupe 78 membres
qui donnent leur avis sur les projets du
territoire la structure va notamment
travailler dans les prochains mois sur
l'économie circulaire ou encore la santé
on est écoute Yve long Dechamp le
co-président du colé ski il s'agit de
prendre du recul essentiellement par
rapport à à l'activité de de définition
de projet de de
l'agglomération puis par ailleurs le
code ski travaille sur l'évaluation des
politiques publiques il s'agit pas
simplement de faire des propositions
mais aussi de de voir si ces ces
politiques publiques atteignent les
objectifs qui sont visés par rapport à
les beaux besoins de la population ou
des acteurs de la société civile jeudi
soir il y a aussi eu une délibération
concernant l'enseignement supérieur une
délibération dans le cadre d'un fond de
concours voté en 2021 qui représente une
somme d'1,5 million d'euros destiné à
l'enseignement supérieur et à la
recherche répartie sur 3 ans cette somme
est destinée à des projets innovants
portés par des universités ou des
entreprises jeudi dernier c'était 300000
€ qui étaient attribué au territoire on
écoute Philippe guigen conseiller
communautaire délégué à l'Enseignement
supérieur de 550 an Livine ça va
de de petits projets de de 20000 € qui
sont des projets inclusifs à des projets
beaucoup plus beaucoup plus importants
comme le projet du du Laboratoire
national d'essaiis de trappe sur la
cybersécurité et l'intelligence
artificielle en quoi c'est important
c'est que nous devons nous sommes un
territoire très attractif et nous devons
le rester aussi bien pour les étudiants
que pour les entreprises donc il est
important que cette image de territoire
dynamique soit colle à la peau de de 51
et enfin Michell il y a eu un vote
concernant les Jeux olympiques de Paris
2024 oui tout à fait Mathilde sur le
même principe que les trottinettes
électriques des vélo assistant assistan
électrique vont être mis en place en
libre service dans 50 ans en livlin
pendant la période des Jeux olympiques
de Paris 2024 la grille tarifaire a été
validée en conseil pour les utilisés des
forfaits à 8 € pour les 30 minutes et 15
€ pour 1 heure seront proposé sinon il
faudra les débloquer pour 1 € et payer
25 5 centimes la minute objectif de
cette mesure encourager la circulation
tous pendant les Jos et bien merci
beaucoup Michel el midoro le prochain
conseil d'agglomération de Saint-Quentin
en Yveline est programmé le 14 décembre
prochain on reste à Saint-Quentin en
Yveline puisque la semaine dernière
avait lieu le acaton à l'OVSQ
l'observatoire de Versailles
Saint-Quentin en Yveline 60 étudiants et
étudiantes de la région parisienne ont
planché sur une question concernant la
la défense spatiale ils avaient pour
mission de de donner une solution en 24
heures un défi lancé par le pôle de
compétitivité Aérospace vallleée quels
sont les objectifs Clara de Frutos a
interrogé le physicien et le vice
président de la recherche et de
l'innovation de l'OVSQ écoutez à def in
space c'est c'est c'est un un mode de de
travail qui est qui qui qui est
différente d'habitude c'est que d'un
seul coup on se dit on a 24 heures pour
essayer d'imaginer quelque chose et du
coup on on on mobilise ces neurones pour
aller trouver des solutions qu'on avait
pas imaginé jusque-l d'accord et donc
comment ça s'est organisé ce alors c'est
le commandement de l'espace qui vient
d'être créé et il a été créé parce que
le domaine du spatial est en pleine
évolution en ce moment dans tous les
niveaux et du coup bien évidemment il y
a des questions de souveraineté des
questions militaires associés et et des
des questions aussi d'encombrement de
l'espace plein de questions qui
finalement sont très important pour
notre vie au quotidien puisqu'on on
dépend beaucoup du satellite les gens
l'ignorent mais presque toute notre vie
dépend des satellites aujourd'hui
maintenant et donc on a besoin
effectivement de de de d'enrichir
finalement ce que on peut faire et et et
la vision que l'on a pour demain tout le
monde
est est intéressé par ça donc c'est
c'est de montrer que finalement le
spatial ne ne se limite pas à Thomas
Pesquet ou Elon Musk qui a beaucoup
beaucoup de d'éléments et que et qu'on a
besoin de tout le monde se mobiliser sur
le spatial c'est un domaine qui va être
ouvert largement à un beaucoup plus
grand nombre de
[Musique]
gens pourquoi tu as participé à ce défi
in space aujourd'hui alors moi je
m'intéresse beaucoup au domaine de la
défense et notamment la défense spatiale
donc je trouve que c'était assez
important quand même que je puisse
participer à ce à ce à ce challenge donc
là en fait on a choisi le défi technique
donc du coup on va devoir trouver donc
une enfin une application enfin
plusieurs applications du moins de
satellite et de constellation civiles au
domaine militaire ben je trouvais que ça
peut être sympa de faire ça avec des
camarades de classe et que c'est une
bonne opportunité de découvrir un peu
plus le ministère des armées et les
constellations de satellite on choisi le
sujet technique du coup on est en train
de de s'intéresser au besoins du
ministère des armées et aprèsre
regardera les constellations qui
existent déjà qui pourrai besoindre à
qui pourrai répondre à ses besoins et
pour cette étape parisienne c'est le
groupe Super qui a remporté le challenge
technique le groupe space Guardian lui a
remporté le challenge généraliste la
dizaine d'étudiants sera donc en finale
à Paris le 12 décembre ils se battront
pour le premier prix une visite du port
spatial européen à Kuru en guyen un peu
de littérature à présent et si c'était
vrai le premier jour toutes ces choses
qu'on ne sait pas dites ces titres de
livre vous disent peut-être quelque
chose Marc Levy était de passage dans
les ivelines à la librairie du pinceret
de poissie l'écrivain français le plus
lu au monde est venu rencontrer ses
lecteurs mais aussi dédicacer son tout
nouveau roman La symphonie des monstres
Régine ralèche est allée à sa rencontre
à la librairie du pinceret à poissie la
queue ne faiblit pas les fans de roman
et en parti parul de Marc lev avait un
rendez-vous important rencontrer
l'écrivain et se procurer son tout
dernier roman ah oui
pourre la symphonie des monstres un
roman dans lequel l'auteur raconte les
raptes d'enfants Ukrainiens depuis
l'invasion de l'Ukraine par la Russie on
parle d'une certaine lassitude par
rapport à la guerre et on parle de
beaucoup de choses mais on parle pas du
tout du sort de ces enfants et je crois
que le roman a le pouvoir de nous faire
ressentir et de nous rapprocher de gens
qu'on croit vivre loin mais qui en fait
sont très proches de nous cadeau à
offrir ou cadeau pour soi-même parmi les
fans des impatients et d'autres qui
devront attendre les fêtes de fin
d'année pour s'y plonger j'ai hâte de
voir ce que Marc Levy voit lui-même à
travers ce livre avant Noël ça fait un
petit cadeau c'est tout parce que Noël
c'est dans un bon mois et quelqu une
séance dédicace qui a eu du succès 300
romans ont été vendus en l'espace de
2h merci beaucoup bonsoir Merci à VOUS
bonsoir du vin du fromage et du chocolat
le weekend dernier se tenait la 12e
édition du salon vin et saveur à poissie
et cette année encore les producteurs
locaux étaient au rendez-vous pour le
plus grand bonheur des gourmets c'était
également l'occasion de découvrir des
produits yvelinois le reportage de
Gabriel
Gontier et si cette année pour les fêtes
vous mettiez l'accent sur les produits
locaux vin biscuit charcuterie ou même
foie gras pour sa 12e édition le salon
vin et saveur de poissie organisé par le
Lyon club a réuni des producteurs de
toute la France c'est le cas de cette
biscuiterie de crépière qui fonctionne
en circuit
court on est une biscuiterie artisanale
qui a été créée il y a 11 ans et on a
ouvert notre miellerie au départ avec
des ruches sur la ferme et ça s'est
étendu sur des ruches un peu partout en
île-de-fance l'idée c'est de valoriser
les produits du terroir d'île-de-fance
on essaie vraiment de montrer que le
terroir d'île-de-fance c'est un tervoir
de de tradition et de qualité purure
beurre chocolat noisette ou même
coqulico ici les biscuitis se déclinent
sous toutes les saveurs même les plus
insolides comme la pétale de rose pour
ces biscuits de marille sur
[Applaudissements]
mold autre tendance des fêtes de fin
d'année le vin et les ivelines aussi ont
leur vigob
on propose les vents qu'on fait dans les
ivelines sur la plaine de Versailles au
village d'Avron donc c'est les premières
domaines vticolî de France une mise en
avant des produits locaux qui ne
laissent pas insensibl les visiteurs
alors le salon V et saveur nous on le
connaît déjà depuis 2 ans et c'est parce
que les exposants c'est souvent les
mêmes d'une année sur l'autre mais ils
sont tous excellents et donc voilà c'est
l'occasion de profiter de bons produit
du terroir et de la région on a déjà
acheté du
vin des terines on va aller voir le foie
gras voilà on a acheté du SER le plus
dur reste donc de choisir quels produits
seront les stars de nos dîners de fin
d'année et c'est bientôt l'heure de
passer aux invités du 78 mais avant je
vous propose de jeter un coup d'œil à la
météo de
[Musique]
demain demain matin nous devrions avoir
un vrai temps de novembre le ciel sera
nuageux du C côté de Mantel jolie et de
versaill verre remembouillé et houdant
attendez-vous à du brouillard au niveau
des températures il fera 8 à 9 degr en
moyenne l'après-midi le ciel sera
toujours aussi couvert dans tout le
département côté température il fera
12°g à ouan Versailles et rouillé et 14°
à Mantel jolie et demain nous fêterons
la saintclément c'est l'heure à présent
de passer aux invités du
et ce soir les invités du 78 viennent
nous présenter l'association h soie
Handicap Société inter d'ako firm domoro
bonsoir bonsoir madame alors vous êtes
le président et le fondateur de cette
association à vos côtés en face de vous
Philippe opéri bonsoir bonsoir vous êtes
le coordinateur de l'association alors
première question d' est-ce que vous
pouvez nous présenter en quelques mots
l'association h sois qu'est-ce que c'est
h sois je vous remercie avant tout
propos je remercie la direction de tv78
avec plaisir nous avoir invité sur le
plateau pour parler de handicap souité
handicap souité c'est H qui a été créé
depuis
2017 en Côte d'Ivoire et nous sommes
installés depuis 2013 sur la Ve de
plaisir et et nous avons mené beaucoup
d'actions de sensibilisation sur le
handicap parce
que quels sont les objectifs de
l'association quel est votre but les ob
le le but c'est que nous recherchons
et l'objectif atteintre que la
population que les personnes qui sont
qui se disent visibles voilà
physiquement sache que chacun de nous un
handicap hm hm et c'est pas parce que
moi mon handicap il est visible que on
doit dore exclu avoir un
certain la privilège mais chacun de nous
a un handicap nous sommes tous des
handicapés potentiels sur cette TER et
alors ce samedi vous organisez pour la
première fois une journée de fête pour
les familles et les enfants en situation
de handicap pourquoi c'était important
pour l'association de d'organiser cette
journée
vous savez nous sommes dans la vie nous
vivons et il a des
C des personnes voilà qui voilà qui qui
sont
marginalisés stématisé et nous comme il
faut nous avons un handicap invisible
les familles
souffre beaucoup du handicap ces
familles sont angoissé par rapport à un
handicap HM donc c'est important de
créer cet événement pour pour rassembler
les familles FIP auéri oui en fait c'est
pour aussi rappeler euh l'aspect
solidarité sociale he parce que c'est
vrai que
euh on est en société on est dans une
société qui qui va très vite et qui qui
qui laisse certaines personnes pour
compte sur la sur le sur le chemin h et
Handicap Société c'est vraiment de
d'essayer de de récupérer de de créer
vraiment déjà dans la proximité le
comment dire la une symbiose la
solidarité la solidarité parce que vous
savez le le le le notre devise euh
liberté fraternité égalité égalité bah
c'est c'est vrai que nous on peut pas
agir sur la liberté sur la la la
l'égalité puisque les législateurs et
les pouir mais vous agissez sur la
fraternité sur la fraternité on peut
agir et donc euh voilà on agit sur la
fraternité mais dans notre environnement
alors quel est le programme de cette
journée alors le programme mais avant
avant exce je pour prend un peuyy je
vourais vraiment au nom de handicap
souhaiter disci beaucoup à Madame le
Maire Joséphine col Colman Berg la M
deoui voilà madame MRI mari qui nous
soutient dans tout ce que nous faisons
voilà chaque année et met à disposition
la salle et donc voilà et je pense que
c'est ça qu'il faut h voilà il faut é
c'est important que la ville s'implique
dans ce genre d'événement d'événements
c'est très important oui à ce propos il
y a il y a même une une permanence qui
est ouverte tous les mercredis de de 14h
à 18h au 98 avenue François mit à la
mosaïque voilà à la mosaïque la salle de
la mosaïque de plaisir de plaisir voilà
donc c'est là aussi qui a lieu
l'événement de sa événement et donc le
programme la accueil commence à à 15h ça
va durer 1hure après on a une allocution
de bienvenue ensuite il va y avoir des
échanges sur le thème que le président a
dit tout à l'heure quel est le thème
c'est pour cette première journée de
fête ouais pour cette première journée
de fait c'est valoriser un regard
positif vis-à-vis des familles et
enfants en situation handicap de la
société d'accord oui parce que c'est
important de souligner qu'il y a aussi
des handicaps qui sont invisibles invisi
voilàis donc il y aura un temps
d'échange voilà voilà donc donc c'est ça
on est dans une société vous comprenez
bien que la souffrance est elle n'est
peut-être pas palpable mais elle est
surnoise elle est et elle est là donc il
va falloir qu'on on se on se on se serre
les coudes et que voilà on cède et donc
c'est un peu ça et nous avons cette
occasion aussi pour dire que il faut que
chaque chaque être humain prenne
conscience que le handicap nous sommes
tous des handicapés potentiels il faut
jamais dire oui nous moi je suis pas
handicapé parce que j'ai eu des
personnes à qui j'ai parlé qui me dit
mais moi j'ai pas d'handicap ça
m'intéresse pas nous sommes tous des
handicapé potentiel que nous vivons sur
cette terre il y a encore beaucoup de
discrimination selon vous aujourd'hui
dans la société envers les personnes en
situation d'hicap bon moi par exemple je
peux dire un truc hein ok clair et je
quand même la Côte d'Ivoire et je suis
arrivé en France à 2000 2010 hm hm mais
depuis que je suis en France j'ai vu que
ok la France respecte les personnes en
situation d' handicap je me suis jamais
senti pueré hm hm j'ai été toujours
accompagné justement et parce que nous
sommes Handicap Société Inter en Afrique
les personnes à sation handicap sont
discriminées d'accord et nous disons
non vous voulez dire quelque
chose non mais c'est c'est important
c'est important de dire voilà tant que
nous vivons tant qu'on vit faut jamais
dire que ça peut pas m'arriver h et
alors pour
l'événement de samedi vous attendez
environ combien de de personnes combien
de familles en alors
50 à 75 mais si s'il y a d'avantage du
monde c'est ouais mais moi je peux dire
que euh que toutes les familles et
toutes les familles qui nous écoutent
sont les bienvenus sont les bienvenus et
puis c'est la première édition c'est la
première édition premère parce que on
veut on veut cette cette manifestation
on la veut annuelle on fait on fait la
fête de la liberté la fête de la Fête de
la Musique la musique par exemple voilà
voilà et ben pourquoi ne pas faire la
fête de des familles qui sont en
souffrance toute l'année et qui ont
besoin de euh de notre de notre
attention aussi vous voyez parce que et
je lance je profite de l'occasion pour
lancer un appel à tous nos partenaires à
tous les responsables tous ceux qui
peuvent nous accompagner les men nous
accompagner parce que notre vision est
claire quand la terre est clair le ciel
est clair la terre est visible voilà il
faut qu'on soit clair et bien merci
beaucoup euh d'co Firma de Morau et
Philippe opéri d'avoir répondu à notre
invitation et d'être venu répondre à nos
questions en plateau alors si vous êtes
intéressé la fête des familles et des
enfants en situation de handicap c'est
ce samedi 25 novembre à la salle de la
mosaïque à plaisir ça commence à 15h et
c'est jusqu'à 21h et c'est la fin de
cette émission merci pour votre fidélité
je vous souhaite une belle soirée sur
tv78 prenez soin de vous
[Musique]
merci